[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please close my lord excellent thing to
do
by a staff now and my vote
[Music]
it's times them I just need a moment
they say an analytics man doesn't have a
heart but I ran the numbers and nothing
could be further from the truth
you are son to me Joelle now that I will
always be watching you I will always
believe in you please forgive me for
leaving I have no choice open the door
you will be the light that pulls this
city from the darkness the fruits of the
process will soon ripen and harvest will
yield great things open the damn door
inky get the battle tram and no matter
what you must always
Oh trust the power remember make sure
they hold on to Robert Covington smooch
and athlete Carrodus
[Music]
[Music]
Michelangelo nothing damn Philadelphia
van always so angry they should be
grateful I got a first-round pick for
Nolan okay fine toppy team protected the
Seminoles there the family could reach
the cattle wall it's going to be fine
father Okafor is guarding the door
holding a door hold the door
hold the door Olga door Okafor
Okafor Okafor that's my mag alors can do
it my god the beads on the table yo
paint a picture of you in a media right
here